vamos a tomar la matriz a y vamos a
sacar su determinante con otro método
podemos usar cualquier método válido que
hay entonces lo que vamos a hacer con
este método es tomar esta columna
y volver a escribir aquí al lado de esta
última raya del determinante así es que
aquí tenemos 44 menos 2
y después vamos a tomar esta otra
columna y vamos a escribirla también
aquí menos 150
y para sacar el determinante lo que
vamos a hacer es tomar estas diagonales
todas las que se puedan o sea está esta
y está ahorita la de circular y
multiplicar todos los números que están
en la diagonal y sumar esas diagonales
ok entonces vamos a tomar esta diagonal
y vamos a multiplicar el 4 por el 5 por
el 0 nos va a quedar 0 a eso le vamos a
sumar lo que nos quede debe multiplicar
todos los números en esta diagonal
y también le vamos a sumar esta diagonal
que son las tres diagonales completas
después a eso le vamos a restar las
diagonales que estén completas en el
otro sentido ok entonces vamos a
restarle esta diagonal vamos a restarle
la multiplicación de este por este por
este y también vamos a restar la
multiplicación de estos tres números y
restar también la multiplicación de
estos números ok entonces finalmente lo
que nos va a quedar es que el
determinante de a es igual a igual y lo
debería de hacer con rojo cuatro por
cinco por cero vamos a escribirlo 4 por
5 por 0 más la segunda diagonal
en este sentido menos 1 por 3 por menos
- 1 x 3
- 2
y nos falta sumar la última diagonal o
sea nos falta sumar 1 por 4 por 0 + 1
por 4 por 0 ok y nos falta restarle
estaría con el menos
la primera diagonal que es menos uno por
cuatro por cero
menos uno por cuatro por cero - la
segunda diagonal o sea cuatro por tres
por cero
4 x 3 x 0 - la tercera diagonal que es 1
por 5 x menos 2 - 1 x 5 x menos 2
ok entonces pues aquí tenemos cuatro por
cinco por cero eso nos da cero y después
estamos sumando menos uno por tres por
menos dos ok
1 por 3 3 por 2 6 y aquí tenemos dos
signos menos o sea que menos por menos y
nos dan más o sea que todo esto es más 6
6 y de aquí uno por cuatro por cero
cualquier cosa x cero es cero y de acá
esto es menos muy importante no olvidar
nunca el menos a mí me ha pasado muchas
veces menos uno por cuatro por cero
esto es cero otra vez menos cuatro por
tres por cero cero otra vez y menos uno
por cinco por menos 21 por 55 por 210 y
aquí tenemos un menos pero aquí también
tenemos un menos menos por menos de más
o sea que aquí tenemos más 10 y
finalmente entonces el determinante de a
igual a 6 más 10 o sea 16 que ese fue
otro método para sacar el determinante
de una matriz de 3 por 3